Let's consider now the real world,
and in particular hedge funds.
So let's consider two real world funds.
One is RenTec or
Renaissance Technologies,
it was founded by Jim Simons, a math and
computer since professor, and
he's had tremendous performance
over the last several decades,
and Warren Buffet,
who runs Berkshire Hathaway.
Both of these funds over the years
have produced similar returns.
But on the one hand,
Warren Buffet holds maybe 120 stocks,
and he doesn't trade much,
he just holds them.
Renaissance technology trades
may be 100,000 times per day.
Can a single theory relate these two?
Can it account vastly widely
differing numbers of trades per year,
and can it relate the fact that
they have similar performance and
maybe different levels of skill?
How does that all work together?
Well, yes,
there is a theory that can relate them,
it's the fundamental law of
active portfolio management, and
I'm going to show it to
you in just a moment.